québec s'étaient sentis épargné mais en
octobre l'entrée de la capitale en zone
rouge a assombri le paysage et aux
prétentions à montréal c'est un mondial
ça se passe niort n'a pas fait attention
il sentait vraiment là on est vraiment
plus de fierté d'une auto on y va
d'autres on coud s'est pas fait prendre
il avait le québec pêché par un chien et
loup où le prix d'un seul dans cette
zone l'autre le caricaturiste andré
philippe côté illustre le quotidien des
gens de québec depuis plus de 25 ans il
a rapidement ciblé le point de départ de
la deuxième vague dans la région
une soirée karaoké au bar le kerouac qui
a fait au moins 80 cas dont un décès et
l'écart au qg ça c'est vraiment excité
le point de bascule
c'était j'ai fait une gradation
là-dessus tout de suite parce que si ces
moments le faut les saisir mais je crois
que la chanson je suis malade allait
bien avec parce qu'il a fait c'est
quelqu'un qui il se pète peau qui est
malade et il faut chanter vos livres en
tout le monde malade choisi l'ironie
quand je suis malade a présenté la chine
ou le conti de la soeur de meredith
monroe est décédé de l'aco vide après
l'avoir contractée au bal kerouac
les deux femmes étaient des habitués de
l'établissement mais elle nie à l'est
plus depuis le début de la pandémie
au début ça me dérange pas de payer un
billet publié le karaoké qui est une
musique c'est quelque chose perdre chez
nous la fin quand benoît à des six
marches à cannes un changement
ce sentiment de vouloir juste une fois
faire fi des mesures sanitaires personne
n'y échappe
mais peu semblent passer de la parole
aux actes la semaine dernière le service
de police de québec a répondu à 91 appel
de dénonciation dix huit rapports et
constats d'infraction ont été émis pour
des manquements aux règles sanitaires
dont je cacherai pas que je disais avec
vous monsieur radio x et 28 décès c'est
ce sont des brèdes et c'est le premier
ministre legault lui s'en est pris à
certains médias
et il n'est pas seul à dénoncer la
désinformation le climat médiatique
pense faudrait en aveugle ou en fait
dans ce cas là sauf pour ne pas
identifier que ça peut être un facteur
qui explique la situation au québec dans
leur mire la station radio x qui a donné
l'antenne à des leaders complotistes
comme alexis cossette trudel alexis
comme sur mon ami ça va bien le bonjour
du off
ça me paraît tellement évident qu'on
peut pas nier la co vite que je sais le
truc prendre un exemple de choses qu'on
peut pas nier que pour un poil ça brûle
mais là j'ai fait un personnes à la
radio qui dit c'est pauvre ex parce que
c'est dangereux le rond-point voyant
avez-vous les chiffres ces quads ou ça a
bien puis les experts n'importe quoi
elle essaye d'aller voir avec marcelo
remparts au troisième
une étude du centre sur les médias de
l'université mcgill établi un lien entre
la désinformation circulant sur les
réseaux sociaux et les comportements qui
amplifie la pandémie une station de
radio en particulier radio x qui a reçu
régulièrement nom de des chefs
complotistes des gens qui propageaient
de la désinformation des gens proches du
mouvement ainsi masquer également c'est
clair que pour certaines de cette place
de catégorie là qu'ils écoutent ces
émissions la basse et des informations
leur est donnée par radio x défend de
propager de la désinformation affirmant
plutôt être ouvert à la pluralité des
points de vue à ce chapitre le directeur
général nous souligne dans un courriel
que les animateurs donne également la
parole à des scientifiques comme le
directeur de la santé publique de québec
je sais que des fois résout excès et
faussement critiquer je pense qu'on a eu
on lui on est critique des décisions
politiques mais pour la santé publique
on est là toujours besoin de l'autre
côté de la rive dans
chaudière-appalaches c'est la
transmission au milieu de travail qui
inquiète c'est plus de 50% de nos
situations présentement l'éclosion
l'usiné olymel en beauce a entraîné à
elles seules 126 cas on travaille on
sait on perd au maire il ya des enfants
donc et ses reflets l'état de la
transmission communautaire dans la
région avec la fatigue face aux mesures
sanitaires et la redondance du message
gardez la population alerte est un défi
de tous les instants selon elle il faut
maintenir l'intérêt il faut voir ont une
formation
transparent il vraiment qu'est ce qui
arrive et qu'est ce qui se passe est
plus que jamais le moral des gens de
québec est mis à dure épreuve
même si un dessin ne guérit rien il peut
adoucir les mots ont dit que l'une au ca
est d'atténuer les qui fait que les
rouages de la société
reims marne on sent vraiment la nouvelle
jean besoin de 7 heures 6 tours leur
quotidien et c'est valérie gamache radio
canada québec
[Musique]